we're on the mexican side right now of
the rio grande that's the river that
separates this country from the united
states and we're here because more than
10 000 people most of them haitian have
crossed this river to get to the united
states and establish a sort of makeshift
camp wanting to be given asylum and to
be able to stay in the united states
many of them traveled through south and
central america to get to this point
they're fleeing poverty and years of
political turmoil and natural disasters
back home
i'm really scared you know why haiti had
an earthquake we were left with nothing
no home no food nothing almost all my
family died and if we don't go across
where are we going to go we don't have a
home that's why we're searching for a
better future
the flow of haitians crossing to the
united states at this point suddenly
turned into a torrent over the last week
or two but now it's slowed again
people have heard the plans from the u s
government to fly many in the camp back
home
we're scared that if we cross they'll
just deport us back to haiti and it will
be worse for us
those we did see crossing the river were
mainly bringing food and water to those
on the other side
i asked this man how people were doing
on the other side
they're okay but sad because maybe
tomorrow they'll be deported
conditions in the camp are reportedly
tough with not enough food toilets or
water but we couldn't verify that
earlier in the day we tried to enter the
camp via the front door in texas we just
tried to get into the camp via the u.s
entry and we were denied there we now
just crossed the river and tried to get
in through this entry port and we've
just been denied by the board of
patrolmen that you can see behind me who
say that we're not allowed in other
journalists said the same the u.s
authorities are blocking the media from
talking to those inside meanwhile
they're faced with the problem that
would test any administration a
makeshift shantytown suddenly springing
up on their border with thousands
desperate to stay
john holman al jazeera acuna mexico